Oh what's it do it it's still fun in the
right direction it's drifting towards us
Paul is flying the climate team's
$80,000 drone system it's fighting so
much wind I just can't handle it and the
winds are gusting to 70 miles per hour
maintain heading I'll tell you when to
turn thank you that's good do a
right-hand turn in three two one now
how's that that's good I mean thin
having that's easy to see them done when
it's blind 54 not you're doing good
we're seeing 60 not every twin speeds
which is very high the most i've ever
flown and it's about 50 knots left-hand
turn a bit keep going but yeah it's
obviously more pressure to make the most
of the remaining time we've got gotta
move south a bit and if we don't fly
they're gonna be missing a large
component of the data that I planned on
getting all right and turn again in
three two one
I mean it just can't handle it too much
waiting for it we'll do a couple more
and we'll call it off your left hand
adjustment a little bit okay cuz its
struggling into that wind it's using
battery up faster than life the land
keep going almost a great time turn Oh
alert battery now if I battery left I'm
coming home okay that's good the team
has a complete data set from higher
altitude but they still need to get the
drone back in one piece we got to figure
out where we're gonna land so let's dry
dusty sand gets into the motor so we're
gonna try and land on this week sand of
course the danger were there is theres a
river so if we overshoot our landing
Eileen don't let drink they'll be bad
the gear is not waterproof you ready
retract the Frog please now on okay the
probe should be retracted okay good
oh you're like ihop the river how cool
is that standing so I from the angle i
standing right there is a better terrain
you can see the skid mark bounced jump
you